I mean baby I almost got it hey you
here's what I mean
would you guys okay all right there we
go I put my balls in my head and say
it's a new hat but it's not oh crap
all right shoot easily explode oh Jesus
ha ha okay let's let's be creative
together let's build some fun so how do
i spool and stuff I forgot
q thank you wait how did don't yell Mari
god oh my god god oh god wait no let me
tell em it slow duck no no like oh I got
this
how dare you what happened
wait who's this guy who's who yeah this
guy here I did that's my dildo don't
mess with my dildo is this your dildo
then yeah
is this your dealer no that's not my
dildo they'll know that would be a weird
dildo Deb oh it's your armadillo I get
it fly craft I know it let's build a
rocket ship and go to space okay we
can't play this map without singing
everything is awesome everything is come
on you another thing everything is ok I
guess he's are you singing that whatever
he says all right that's good Hey all
right in Jackson I'm sitting wait I want
to sit on it wait oh you both wanna be
what is not gonna work you all right
whatever this is what's gonna happen
tell me where you need to get out any 2d
mark when you took my seat how much
we'll get on it then I rocket
here we go god oh god here we go no I'm
not freezing whatever what is life oh no
smoothie oh okay we'll hit grab MJ I got
I gotta for one sec are you around okay
oh no so what are you throwing me around
bad I'm good ha ha oh my god
are you second the ground the ground
yep you know yo you went inside a house
come da underground
where's Mike oh yeah the thing is still
going oh gosh ah what is happening it
was me violet I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry guys ah you're not sorry I
could be I don't okay I have a better
idea uh we should be a helicopter that
actually works
Wow okay has this ever been done before
no problem Wow all right this is a good
base my little put chairs on it
okay so sorry sorry but like I don't
think it would leave me this big until
us reverse oh that's our helicopter
rotor oh I got you is a little big let
me check fine a small one
sure there you go oh god it's making
love with her everything it went inside
it hell doc now how will it spin mark
I'm let's spend hang on are we all gonna
spin is that the place okay fine it
doesn't look very straight Mario I don't
know if that matters it doesn't matter I
don't know why we'd go through somebody
effort when literally they will have the
same effect that's the first thing no no
you ready for the test run let's say the
first helicopter I mean Jima
here we go do it count 3 2 1 go ha ha ha
I forgot that freeze things hang on I
thought I was just getting too fat okay
countdown to 10 from Tang Wei no no no
I'm not even ready wait well it needs
some more ideas not a son I need
decoration ok kids I need a lot of
deckard dicks ok green chick um in case
wrote that's a mean room no what's that
spawning cross what is nice crow
oh Jesus dude what if we put a car on
top of it what are you willing you just
broke it
Bravo hey the [ __ ] oh you're all
that is not good all right shake that's
not good I don't know you see but that's
I see everything
oh you guys look it's the same thing I'm
looking at holy crap happen I'm Lucas
realization
well I barely touch it on it again
you're damn CRO screwed everything up my
terms are like floating in infinity over
there oh my god Oh God
and how I did kill me well then there
he'll be all creation with me I'm trying
to grab it wait I didn't get it I
deleted it oh good okay try again this
time we build a helicopter from the car
I got I got I got this I got this guy
all right we need a bigger head this
thing bigger rotor yeah that was the
problem that was yeah yeah oh so the
problem
yeah things working bacon gonna be
that's gonna be the attaching point okay
uh yeah yes it in not even close
I'm taking this I'm just taking the
audio of this way out of context do I
need it once the burner like more in
your chore just going forward okay let's
stick it right there stop oh oh oh hold
it hold it hold it still I'm trying okay
okay cuz that's what times okay well
then I want still for you okay no no
okay hold it right there and it there
I'm gonna weld it keep holding it lit up
well it fits well in it's welded okay
it's welded crap that one's frozen pan
don't there we go okay okay yeah it's
not really stable oh no no that's okay
mmm guys doing it and we're totally
doing it sit still goddamn it you didn't
wait Melanson yeah well is that Amir all
right we obviously need another car on
the other side to stabilize the weight
you're right you're right all right back
now will ya hold that not okay
that's welded up night wait no that's
wrong now you watch oh oh oh God
all I undid everything okay it's fine
it's like is that we can actually do it
correctly all right yes we can I guess
I'll have to put it inside you again
yeah oh yeah wait that's not at all Sol
Sol I'm gonna fly like the fanfictions
get the better of me there I'll make
sure it doesn't ever leave and it's
stable too it's stable okay we need some
really powerful butters if this gonna
work a fly you ready ready to fly this
is ready
um and we need why he's too fast it's
working okay
well I think we need more power so just
over here with firefighters you should
they're very amazing ouch
oh god it's Carly I'm pretty amazed how
oh it actually is fun yeah yeah way we
need stay then we need to decorate in
why do we kill not again let's go for
the next time you decorated it all for
oh god oh god
see that's just what you deserve okay
let's not decorate it then yeah but if
people judge judge because we have an
ugly helicopter okay okay well nothing
was lost sorry
go do it go just go here we go here we
go let's go we can what go let's go yes
oh my god that was whoa what happened
okay I don't want to be mean to you guys
but I think the decoration is the reason
why I didn't work realizing is this okay
get back here Sally sue come over here
oh my god I'm so scared
oh my god oh it's really stuck now I
mean lemme yeah I almost got it yeah
yeah you guys what I mean where'd you
guys
okay all right there we go
all right I have a better idea I have a
better idea we could do we could make a
slingshot and and sling each other we
could how do we do I like that idea can
we get into this abomination yeah and
then if we how are we gonna sling it
yeah we were just used to prop gun or
whatever
no sorry they again yeah we just drag
them we need a chair in here
okay let's put a chair yeah I don't know
where you're going with this
yeah what are we trying to accomplish oh
okay hey I love it this is the best okay
let's try this again
okay idea was to pull it back and then
launch it oh I got it well that's
actually really smart I don't think he's
gonna work out the way you thank you
sorry I think I broke it - okay does
anyone want to sit in this chair then it
should be fine I'll be the guinea pig
whoop come in go for it all right you
ready uh-huh happening I think hit the
mat Baha your guinea pig does not
appreciate this terrible idea hey you
ready go on three okay one two three
we like going time yeah let's try that
again
when we ready - didn't work I kind of
work actually I went a distance the
thing I just instant okay mark this says
he's marked yeah don't worry until every
guinea I'm a winner
okay Jack your your turn just see how
far you can go yes ah I'm not really
inside the cube but that's fine I mean I
mean who cares yeah that looks good boss
out looks good looks good okay what is
life what has happened is it it work hey
uh hey we can out you here there Jerry
we're not freaking it out
that's jag distance by distance
I used a key it's gotten you yeah but
all you can go out now ready go so
excited go in this one I will give you a
beautiful wet kiss I'd rather not can
you just give me cash or something or
like a hahaha
Amazon giftcard let me go already my
uncle has to around I'm all up your ass
I'm all the way I win America that's the
only slap I can do no that was my I
fight ah
hey Danny whenever I'm surprised that I
actually work holy [ __ ] yeah this is
beautiful that it then yeah we should be
old a baby mobile yeah I like that
so Justin well these together okay yeah
we all look old anymore oh sorry I click
run I think you're lagging the server I
literally have no well privileges
anymore I'm sure yeah [ __ ] is happening
let's just take two babies no sorry
three babies but Chariton babies one for
each of us yeah no actually I was gonna
get two but okay I guess I can come see
what a complex now let's put wheels on
it let's maybe we haven't build a car
yet yes TP hits
I don't Oh what did I do
I don't know wheel disappeared Nicole
the baby Gerry yeah goddamn you Jack I
didn't hate there's nothing wheel on
here I forget baby just took off oh my
god that was amazing
wheels we have four babies out there did
they fornicate I mean yes babies they
reproduce here we go baby care well they
need to be more stable Ami's did you did
you weld oh that's an actual wheel that
actually works yeah
it's working yeah babies dance fashion
Wow work anymore what do you do I kill
them
really oh okay how do we sit on this
this is different
oh I had an idea okay wait no yeah you
do your baby thing I'm gonna I'm gonna
experiment over here I haven't I do your
baby through it I want to build together
no no no no I got it whatever Haley go
is about building taken oh wow and we
get some speed going you're bad with
babies
Oh like a running start yeah yeah it's
charging stable you need ministro my god
they're dancing I can't stop I can't
world it's all oh my god I like this
idea mark oh my god oh my god how do we
go third person again oh my god Oh
everybody that a big beautiful picture
my life history life oh sorry we gonna
do a thumbnail don't know I don't know
pretty oh you like beautiful picture
like way at first let me take a tumble
wish I was a commuter super chef or
thumbnail the thumbnail maybe have a
look strike a pose you're beautiful Oh
Tiger roar Oh beautiful oh my god high
fives all around
yeah ahh why was my high five okay can
we do a Proteus on three everybody
professed previus for aphasic yeah you
fisted me too hard I'm sorry mark it's
better now keep wishing him a crunch
squish oh you high five to Hard Rock
giant our nudes was the fisting champion